and there are some rumors out there that
some high-profile defensive players in
the afc east could be traded and one
that has bubbled up and albert breer of
si.com was talking about this somewhere
recently and
i i was kind of surprised by it but it's
worth mentioning
stefan gilmore could the patriots really
move stefan gilmore the defensive player
of the year now they gave him some more
money before the season started he's
under contract through 2021
that's a stunner to me that it would
even be a point of conversation chris i
uh agreed i mean uh i i don't know if
i'm gonna buy it yet now you know i know
it's albert breer he's pretty connected
with the new england patriots things
like that up there in boston to where
maybe he knows something we don't but
i'm not gonna buy it until i hear a
little bit more of a confirmation i'm
not trying to be disrespectful to
aberbree or anything like that but just
yeah i mean they're predicated on their
secondary you know what he does is so
much a part of their success because of
who he can match up with and it allows
them to do all these different things
off of it you know that i mean last week
on big third downs it was stefan gilmour
versus george kittle i mean that's
that's what they did so i would have a
hard time thinking that bill belichick
would part with that
unless
maybe like you said in the first segment
mike unless new england's starting to go
there's no way we can win the super bowl
this year
you know we're out of it maybe we get to
the playoffs but who cares we don't play
for playoffs we play for super bowl
let's worry about next year jc jackson
we're gonna have to pay him at some
point maybe but i just i would have a
hard time thinking that right now at
this point of the year
and we know that bill belichick
approached get rid of a guy one year too
early instead of one year too late
they're seeing something that the rest
of us don't that would constitute
slippage or just the fact that well
gilmore came back to the trough for more
money that doesn't usually sit well with
the folks in new england maybe that has
fueled some sort of a sense that now's
the time to sell the asset and
ultimately that's i i hate that because
it removes the humanity from the sport i
know but that's the reality these teams
are constantly churning assets who are
human beings who they have to make a
decision does this guy still have a
place on this team does he not is this a
moment where we can get more for him
than we would get next year or even in
the off season right maybe there's a
contest maybe they can dump him onto the
lions for their first round pick next
year chris i mean listen they'd probably
be able to get a king's ransom for him
still he is still
a top-tier corner in football there is
slippage though to your point i mean
it's not as dominant as it's been the
previous two or three years it's not
definitely not he's still one of the
best pure cover corners out there but
last few years you can literally go oh
gilmore's on him shut down forget it you
know maybe that guy gets two or three
catches okay so what this year we've
seen some moments of you know there was
a moment or two last week with kittle
beating them you know we saw dk metcalf
have his way a little bit here and there
with them so yeah there's moments there
to where to your point and you've always
said this where maybe bill does see like
hey there's slippage but his value's
still really really at a peak you know
as far as that's concerned um but i just
still at this point i know it's two and
four
i just i just don't think new england
would throw in the towel quite yet i
guess that's where i just don't don't
buy it yet
it's it's like knowing when to dump a
stock and you have inside information
and bill belichick has more information
than anyone else about the stock that is
stefan gilmore and this may be the time
to dump it and get maximum value it's
that simple and again i hate that
because it removes the humanity from the
sport but the humanity necessarily is
removed you have to have a ruthlessness
to you when you just move these pieces
around on a chessboard what are we going
to do what move are we going to make
when are we going to part ways with a
guy that can maybe set us up to get
better talent next year and beyond if we
can find someone who will give us a lot
more now for staphon gilmore than maybe
they would in the off season xavien
howard signed a long-term contract in
2019 that made him technically the
highest paid corner in football new
money average yadda yadda it wasn't as
great of a deal as it was sold to be but
still it showed a long-term commitment
the dolphins want him they're all in
unless they aren't now this is an
interesting dynamic that emerged
yesterday it is very interesting because
you've got you've got multiple
newspapers in south florida that caught
wind of the fact that teams were calling
the dolphins about xavier howard right
they're making the phone calls and that
in and of itself is newsworthy but you
have to couch it
the right way yes you're not shopping
him we've been down this road before
with other players you're not shopping
and you're not picking up the phone
saying hey do you want this guy do you
want this guy do you want this guy
you're just sitting back and people are
making you offers and teams are very
prickly about that distinction because
they don't want to create the impression
they are motivated to sell that's right
this is basic negotiation there's a big
difference
i mean your best leverage is i'm keeping
the guy right that's your best leverage
what what are you talking about you want
to trade this guy i'm keeping him oh
first round pick uh i'm keeping him well
first round picking the second round
pick um uh i'm keeping him you know i
mean but but that's that's how you sell
and drive up the price so
what ultimately happened was
omar kelly of the south florida sun
sentinel said that the dolphins are
exploring
trade offers for zambian howard joe shad
of the palm beach poached uh post chimed
in and said that's true
and then came a statement from the team
throwing shade at the the sun setting or
the yeah journalism and whatnot what the
truth was they are getting calls they're
getting calls that's what barry jackson
the miami herald ultimately said they're
getting calls the herald knew about it
the herald didn't run with it i don't
know why they didn't run but well i
think maybe i do know why the dolphins
talk them out of it and they have to
cover the dolphins so sometimes you play
ball with the pro football team that you
cover that's right as a publication yeah
but uh you know they're getting calls
okay they're getting calls well that
doesn't mean they're going to trade him
that doesn't mean they want to trade him
but it means they're getting calls and
the question is do they get an offer
they can't refuse
yeah well i think you know first off i i
respect the dolphins i feel like had to
come out pretty strong here just to be a
little defiant because there is a big
difference you don't want to start that
in your locker room you know again yeah
it's one thing like you said for teams
to call and go hey you got a lot of good
corners is xavier howard by any chance
maybe available there's a difference
than that then team them calling around
the league going you know hey we got
xavier howard available we don't want
him we noticed you might be a little
light in the corner there's a you know
the cornerback department that there's a
huge difference there and you don't want
to start issues with the football player
because the football player you know
that second for instance will get
personal oh damn you're trying to shop
me and get me out of town you don't
really want me as compared to oh
people are calling because they think
i'm kind of good and maybe we got good
corners here and you'll get rid of me
there's a big difference in that now and
i think that's what would happen i would
be shocked first off they got it going
finally in miami and one of the reasons
they got it going is because of this guy
you know we just talked about belichick
in the secondary well brian flores came
from new england this secondary is very
important and this was was this his
first contract as a head coach right
that's where i couldn't i was like wait
brian flores got there and the first
thing they did was sign xavien howard i
would be shocked if they were abandoning
ship a year later now i think teams
probably are wondering just a little bit
because hey they paid byron jones and
i'm going to mess up this name but their
first round pick noah igbonye about
igbonyanye i'm sorry i'm sorry i gotta
practice it
he's really damn good too so i think
probably teams look at and go damn they
have two good corners maybe they're
willing to get rid of one uh but i i
don't think that's the case right now
with what they've built i mean they're
pretty damn good in past defense
but here's the reality yeah
they're not slamming the phone down no
they're not of course
everybody's available mike in football i
mean there's only a handful of guys
there's only a handful of guys who are
untouchable that's the point that i was
making about michael thomas earlier this
week yeah
would the saints entertain offers well
it depends on what someone's ought to be
it wasn't
try to get it try to get another team to
maybe make an offer yeah there was that
doesn't mean
that that they would do it but it also
doesn't mean you slam the phone down i
think you slam the phone down for
patrick mahomes you slam it down for
russell wilson yeah you slam it down do
you slam it down for kyle murray i think
you slam it down right now you do you do
slam it down i think you do yes agree
you slam it down for lamar jackson right
don't you yes right agreed that's it
from a quarterback standpoint am i
missing someone
i'd be i'd be quarterback oh yeah i mean
you know yeah i don't know you know of
course aaron rodgers and josh allen pop
into my mind a little right now to where
i'd be very scared to abandon ship on
either one of them i mean i would be
scared to because i'd be scared like oh
we traded him but damn there he is being
a superstar and winning a super bowl and
throwing in our face so but i think your
point's real as quarterbacks i think
those are the
the definite ones yes
yeah now and defensive players like
aaron donald would be it maybe
maybe one of them or both of the bosses
i don't know nick's guy yeah see ellie's
coming off of nick's probably
yeah nick and joe probably all right
there aren't many guys
where you hit the when you see the phone
ring you hit the button that says
decline and there's a more colloquial
name for the button uh that we can't use
did i i i don't know i mean i assume
that that's widely used the
never mind let's just move on i don't
know what the hell you're talking about
you got me confused here
what we'll talk about during oh no we'll
revisit the next segment i'm gonna bring
it up and hopefully hopefully our mics
will be down when we talk about it last
one quinn and williams there's talk that
the third overall pick in the 2019 draft
is available he was on siriusxm scc
radio last night basically hey what all
i do is show up and work what can i do
i mean
i think anybody currently playing for
the jets would be thrilled to be traded
to another team at this point frankly
right well let me put yourself in their
shoes wouldn't you would that would that
would you're like being rescued i i yeah
i mean there is something i mean if
you're a player in the jets right now
there's no light at the end of the
tunnel that would be frustrating you'd
be going damn it doesn't even look like
we can be really competitive next year
so when the hell does that happen quinn
and williams is starting to pop for
their football team he is i mean the i
think the reason
mike really he's probably being thrown
out there and trade talk is he's the
only trade asset they have on the
football team and they're such a bad
team they're looking for anything just
to rebuild restart assets whatever it is
but he's probably the biggest chip they
have as far as in the game that way and
they're probably just dangling and out
there going man maybe somebody will be
stupid and give us something great to
where we can kind of reorganize our team
here going in the future
and he was drafted by the last gm not
the current yeah that's right
so it's easier to justify making that
move
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports